Why Does Mint Tastes Cold?
Similar to why peppers taste hot, what’s
going on here is there is a chemical in mint,
menthol, which is tricking the brain into
thinking that the area the menthol is applied
to is cold; even though in fact, it’s the
same as it was before.
More specifically, menthol binds with cold-sensitive
receptors in your skin; these receptors contain
things called “ion channels”, in this
case TRPM8.
The menthol makes these much more sensitive
than normal, so they trigger and you feel
a cold sensation, even though everything is
more or less the same temperature as before.
This extra sensitivity is why when you eat
peppermint, which has a relatively high level
of menthol, and then you breathe in deeply
through your mouth, your mouth feels extra
cold.
Your cold receptors are reacting much more
strongly than they normally would to the air
which is cooler than the inside of
your mouth.